maintenant en route pour mexico
un petit garçon mexicain passionnés de
musique se retrouvent à l'occasion de la
fête des morts au pays des ancêtres où
il se lie d'amitié avec un spectre qui
va lui révéler l'histoire de sa famille
tel est l'argument du nouveau dessin
animé des studios pixar réalisé donc
parlions creek et adrian molina c'est la
première fois que le studio américain
pixar s'inspire du voisin mexicain
ministre l'événement mais oui absolument
surtout que pixar nous a habitués à ce
que les machines fassent leur cinéma on
a pas mal théoriser sur le fait que
pixar portait en son sein la défaite de
l'humanité contre la victoire de l'ère
mécanique et or là on est déjà à des
années lumières de toy story 2 cars
puisqu'on est plongé dans un grand bain
bouillonnant de culture mexicaine
on est dans une grande déclaration
d'amour à ce pays que l'actuel président
américain a voulu clôturé derrière un
mur je vous propose de découvrir deux
petits extraits que j'ai collé voilà ça
commence quasiment comme un comme un
roman à la dickens un petit garçon
pauvre qui rêve de faire de la musique
alors on lui dit son copain la ludi bas
et stéphane la musique séjour des morts
c'est l'occasion elle lui dit ben non je
ne peux pas car la musique est bannie
dans ma famille
oui la musique est banni car un ancêtre
pas très gentil appliqué à plaquer
mairie fille pour pouvoir pour son art
alors il faut essayer lui dit son
compagnon mais la catastrophe
évidemment la sentence ne se fait pas
attendre et débarque la grand-mère de
coco qui est maître ya assez autoritaire
et l' enfer de quasiment dans la comédie
on a plongé dans quasiment dans le
théâtre de boulevard et c'est à présent
dans un monde totalement onirique et
merveilleux voilà c'est pixar là on est
dans l'âme estrie à la palette numérique
sublime magnifique regarderont si on est
sur un pont de feuilles dorées c'est
absolument sublime et voilà quelle est
la réponse d'hollywood au mur de trump
est vaste et magnifique édifice céleste
chatoyant luxuriant avec cette musique
c'est un des premiers films musicale ces
deux de pixar il faut le dire
voilà il faut dire aussi que lyon creek
marie c'est l'auteur de toy story 3 qui
est l'un des films les plus sombres de
pixar ce coco est il aussi destiné aux
âmes sensibles
évidemment d'abord à vous arracher nous
de larmes
c'est le but quand je dis arraché je le
dis à dessein parce que bon on voulait
tire un peu au forceps à la à la fin
alors tout ce que tu as dit je le
partage et voilà on l'a vu mais c'est
sympa ça pique ça reste à faire c'est
beau c'est enlever c'est drôle et c'est
pour moi ça reste quand même largement
en dessous des chefs-d'oeuvre que
j'adore chez eux
et là je pense à monstres et compagnie
je pense à lao et je pense surtout à vis
versa et ce qui me chagrine
peut-être parce que je suis pas une
fille très sensible au folklore d'une
manière générale et aux légendes et
caetera et que la psychanalyse
m'intéresse davantage et que le côté
conceptuelle des scénarios des
précédents pixar qui arrivait à ronda
matérialisée par le dessin des trucs
complètement dingue des idées des
abstractions qui allaient chercher très
loin et qui me bouleversait ici voilà
c'est un scénario assez programmatique
moi j'ai au moins 20 minutes où je
m'ennuie
le signal jamais arrivé dans un pixar
par agathe or c'est pas le point fort
entre guillemets de l'univers est très
commun avec la profondeur des champs la
lafa le tout le folklore est
effectivement très magnifique et le côté
presque réaliste la sensation d'être au
mexique avec eux après moi c'est qui me
fait rire et je trouve enfin un projet
singulier c'est que là c'est la réaction
des enfants
face à ce film parce que c'est les
gamins ont l'habitude de voir des pixar
ils ont leur leur pyjama reine des
neiges la leur couette cars et d'un seul
coup il arrive hélas pas préparé par ton
quand on va voir un film de burton en
disant on va avoir pas et ça a été le
choc
c'est à dire dans la salle il y en avait
qui par terre en hurlant il y en avait
qui qui demandaient des explications à
leur mère d'autres qui était hypnotisé
et du coup bon il y en a qui en
parleront à l'abc dans 20 ans mais il ya
un truc ou du coup ça leur ramène une
qualité enfin il était presque j'ai
senti la presse et des projections mais
j'ai l'impression qu'ils étaient aussi
bouleversé parle du dock des graphismes
fou du film aussi est pris dans cet
univers un peu plus complexe il faut je
trouve je trouve qu'il faut dédier à la
main d'abord ce qui est rendu vraiment à
la culture mexicaine
c'est quand même incroyable parce que
pixar connaît extrêmement bien cette
culture connaît exerce extrait
extrêmement bien pardon muerto cette
fête des morts et d'ailleurs il ya un
plan qui révèle vraiment qu'ils ont
compris tout la spiritualité et ils font
même des gags qui sont extrêmement
savoureux où il montre vraiment qu'ils
ont compris comment ça fonctionne et
quelle était la mentalité des gens au
mexique il ya par exemple les morts pour
pouvoir revenir pendant muertos il doit
se passer comme une douane l'aéroport et
à chaque fois ci leurs photos et sur un
autel et bien à ce moment là ils peuvent
revenir et y en a un que tout le monde a
oublié
comme souvent les personnages chez pixar
sont voués à l'oubli et lui à chaque
fois ce qui fait chaque année pour
essayer de repasser il se déguise en
frida kahlo c'est quand même génial ça
c'est ça c'est le running gag génial du
film c'est frida kahlo sous toutes les
coutures qui traduit peut-être un moment
que le mexique en a ras-le-bol qu'on ne
parle que de vous et la catho mais c'est
extrêmement drôle philippe et marie
peut-être que si tu as été un petit peu
embêté c'est que le début du film me
semble comme tu le vis très
programmatique et au début je me dis je
vais peut-être un petit peu m'ennuyer
est en fait le film gagne parce que
finalement c'est plus compliqué qu'il
n'y paraît c'est à dire que il ya quand
même cette idée d'aller de la mort vers
la vie et non de la vie vers la mort et
de se baser sur le cinéma parce que ce
type qui est
au delà de la famille qu'est le roi de
la guitare etc qui a plaqué tout le
monde
il a aussi fait des tas de films et
c'est à deux films sont sans cesse
projeté dans le film et on s'aperçoit
que le petit garçon qui est fan de ses
films et vidéos comme tous les gens qui
sont faites de reproduisent dans la vie
les paroles etc
mais en même temps on découvre petit à
petit on va découvrir la jeunesse de ces
films qui sont eux-mêmes nourrit de la
vie et il ya ce mouvement entre la ville
cinéma qu'est nourrie par le principe de
la fête des morts ou si t'as pas ta
photo tu n'existes pas tu vas mourir tu
vas et tu effaces sèche seuil américain
pas à écouter car et 35 et le côté
social c'est à dire que c'est le cinéma
qui va le cinéma et l'image qui va
apporter la vie et qui va permettre la
région
aussi il ya aussi cette idée tu parles
de cette superstar de la musique de la
culture mexicaine y 6 un superbe film
sur l'imposture et là on peut qu'on peut
vraiment lire comme une métaphore du
bras de fer pixar disney pendant des
années avant que finalement disney
engloutissent pixar c'est que celui qui
gagne à la fin c'est pas celui que la
société du spectacle met en lumière
c'est évidemment l'artiste cacher
l'artiste pas reconnue qui est dans son
petit laboratoire musical qui écrit tous
en fête qui est le vrai génie mais qui
n'est pas elvis en gros et cette
critique là cette espèce d'imposture de
la société du spectacle elle et elle est
totalement déplier dans le film pour le
mexique pour le monde des ancêtres et
pour le cinéma allait donc au cinéma est
demandée coco